and now for something different a living
lab for global impact we're going to try
and rift off the inspiration that we've
had from last night this morning in this
afternoon so without further ado I'm
going to turn to Jay we're going to
introduce and then I'm gonna lay out a
vision my name's Jay apt I'm a professor
here at temper and also in the
Department of Engineering public policy
in CIT my colleague Ranger Morgan and I
co-direct the Carnegie Mellon
electricity industry Center our Advisory
Committee tells us we're the largest
interdisciplinary Center in the world
studying how the electric power industry
of tomorrow will get created my name is
Anita Williams Willie I'm an associate
professor of organizational behavior in
theory here at The Temper school I study
collective intelligence and we would
like to find a way to raise levels of
collective intelligence in groups and
across the globe higher than the world
has ever seen I'm a professor in the
robotics Institute I am here to
represent the AI and robotics
perspective through the work of all of
my colleagues in the robotics Institute
of which I am the director I'm Jay
Aronson not J apt and I was actually
afraid that J Whittaker would be here
and that would be really confusing but
but he's not here today I am a professor
of science technology and society in the
history department and I also found it
and direct the Center for human rights
science and the goal of the center is
really to level the playing field
between government corporate and
military actors who start with a great
technological advantage and the human
rights advocates and institutions who
hold them accountable I'm Sarah
Mendelson I'm the head of the Hyatts
program in Washington DC and a
distinguished service professor of
public policy I'm also a Human Rights
practitioner and scholar Russia scholar
and development specialist and I'm going
to talk to you today about growing the
generation that will demand and deliver
the sustainable development goals can we
have the periodic chart up there we go
the what this
stainable Development Goals so three
years ago in September 2015 we the
international community did something
truly remarkable we agreed on an agenda
that will run through till 2030 to make
the world a more peaceful just inclusive
planet to radically reduce poverty and
to address climate change among 17 other
goals 169 targets you're looking at the
periodic chart
now this agenda called the sustainable
development goals or the SDGs emerged
after years of negotiation and
engagement with millions of people
around the world especially with young
people this agenda applies to all of us
and I think it is a great framework for
the work that goes on at Carnegie Mellon
University that these goals are
universal represents a pretty profound
paradigm shift in Development Studies
this is not about the global North
talking to the global South this is
about recognizing that all of us every
country every society we in the United
States also are in a process of
developing maybe the most important
aspect of this is the need to listen and
respond to citizens to people whether in
downtown Pittsburgh in Paris in Prague
or in Panama City and while this agenda
was launched at the UN where I had the
privilege to serve in order for this
agenda to have an impact it has to be
locally owned you shouldn't think about
these as the UN goals you should think
of them as our goals or the global goals
now this agenda can help address
pressing issues that are before our
country and I would argue it can help
support democracy dignity truth and
freedom of expression in other words
these goals can help shore up what we
call the liberal world order so that's
all good news the less good news is that
very few people know about the SDGs now
I think this is about to change and it's
going to change for a couple reasons
not the least of which is that in 2019
they're going to be several heads of
state meetings on the SDGs and that
a tendency to propel action so it's
gonna be in the air but we need to grow
now the generation that is going to
demand and deliver the SDGs what I call
cohort 2030
what's cohort 2030 these are global
citizens born after 1980 who are tech
savvy they're are digitally fluent and
generally they want to use their their
tech skills to solve societal problems
these are the Public Interest
technologists they tend to be very
intolerant of corruption and this is a
real Achilles heel for a lot of
dictators around the world they're very
focused on reducing inequality a lot of
these people you see it in their
applications they live through the
global recession of 2008 they're very
sensitive to it
they are generally very interested in
diversity inclusivity whether it's on
LGBT gender disabilities of course they
want to address climate change generally
they're interested in ethically sourced
products sounds like CMU students right
so the challenge is how do we grow
cohort 2030 and what I'm laying out here
for you is in the early months of
starting this now I'm also in the early
months of being part of the CMU
community this work is being done in
collaboration with the Rockefeller
Foundation but also an organization
called the International Youth
Foundation the president of which is a
woman named Susan Reich Lee who has been
an adjunct faculty member for heights in
Washington DC for several years so
here's what we're trying to do together
the first strategy is we're trying to
identify outstanding examples of cohort
2030 young people who are already
working on the SDGs and bring them
together so can we go to the next slide
this is ladies and gentlemen cohort 2030
this is at the Bellagio Center in Italy
this summer after an international
competition we were able to select 20
people from around the world including a
Heinz alum which was a random thing we
didn't set out to choose or include a
Heinz person but she she really shone
another strategy is addressing data gaps
we really want to know
at cohort 2030 in any given location
thinks about where their passion points
are related to the SDGs we want the data
to be able to impact policy and we look
forward to working with cities and
especially mayor's who are interested in
the sustainable development goals what
better place to start than in Pittsburgh
and we have a private sector partner
who'll be doing that with us in the
coming months the most important
long-term strategy for growing cohort
2030 is of course the university
teaching training and researching the
SDGs it's about field building the next
generation of solvers skilled and using
data and tech to deliver the SDGs this
of course includes high it's college but
it could also include computer science
social scientists business engineering
and arts and entertainment the strategy
also includes experimental learning
capstone students capstone projects that
students are already doing on the SDGs
it's about our alums who for example are
working on reducing food waste here in
Pittsburgh now while not necessarily
under the rubric of the SDGs there is
obviously a ton of work going on at CMU
I think you've even heard about it this
afternoon that could be considered
relevant including at the Scott
Institute for energy innovation the
Steinbrenner Institute for environment
education and research the work that
goes on at metro 21 and the block Center
for technology in society there is room
for growth the strategy could involve
educating undergraduates to be literate
in the SDGs it could involve
collaboration with other great American
universities that are already aligning
with the SDGs it could involve CMU
Africa and the SDG Center for Africa
which is also based in Kigali Rwanda
together supporting experimental
learning and research it could mean
working on delivering outstanding
rankings as Times Higher Education in
2019 begins to measure how universities
are advancing the SDGs you get the point
there's a significant amount of work
that funders are doing foundations
corporations
creating partnerships to deliver the
SDGs around the globe by aligning the
work with st geez we not only have a
common framework we'd be able to
highlight our global impact for this
next generation as it is determined to
leave no one behind
reduce corruption increase education for
girls and human trafficking reduce
violence make electricity accessible for
all so let me stop there and say that
anyone in the university who wants to
know more about cohort 2030 or the SDGs
their email address at the bottom cohort
2030 at andrews CMU edu or email me s
Mendelson at CMU edu now rather than
think of the SDGs as 17 separate goals
the best practice these days is to think
in terms of interconnectedness the
clusters whether it's in climate change
or the cluster that Isak human rights
activism particularly interested in the
goal of making our societies more
peaceful just and inclusive now let's
talk about interconnectedness for the
work that we're doing aspects including
culture politics economics societal
issues all come into play
probably in energy you see as much the
politics of anything i as in in any of
the work that we're doing so Jay why
don't we kick it off with you I'd be
happy to build on what you said about
access of electricity to all if I could
have the first slide in the u.s. we use
now 14 times more electricity than we
did when I was born in the next slide
you can see in the world we're using
about double the electricity that we did
in 1990 and it's doubling every 23 years
that means we get the opportunity to
build a whole new electricity system
every 23 years well unfortunately in the
past that growth has been accompanied by
tremendous pollution you heard and saw
in some of Ellis slides the results of
that pollution and you have to look no
further
than Beijing to see what happens when
you have unscrewed coal plants putting
out electricity and pollution but in
1970 CMU economists showed for the first
time rigorously the connection between
air pollution and human health that led
directly to the Clean Air Act of 1970
and the low pollution electric power
that we see today that provides about
40% of u.s. electricity now we're a long
way behind Europe where they have 55%
low pollution power wind power actually
got its start in Europe due to
government policies and let me show you
in the next slide if we can get the
animation working wind powers growth in
Europe that's an outline of Europe
although it's a little light in here to
see the country boundary but you can see
when growing from Denmark and then
spreading to the rest of Europe Germany
first Spain next France and England and
this growth has just been phenomenal but
still wind and solar power provide only
15 percent of Europe's electric power
and about half that in the US but it is
growing the next slide will show you
country by country in these animations
done by ILA's create lab how wind power
has grown and China is coming on strong
although they have a lot of wind they
have a lot of electricity and so it's
still a small percentage of power but
the thing that ties this together with
what sarah has been saying is that wind
solar hydroelectric and biomass power
they've all run into opposition because
they use a lot of land they for example
the cape winds project off Cape Cod was
stopped dead this year because it marred
the view CMU psychologist Baruch
fish-off and I have collaborated on a
bunch of projects to try to understand
how energy projects and people can work
together to get acceptable outcomes
if I get over the next slide I want to
come back to something that Sarah said
about access this is a of course a
famous picture of nightlights
taken from the defense meteorological
satellite program there's a lot of areas
that don't have lights and the next
billion people to get electric power are
going to get in a very different way
than the people who have electric power
now our students have brought
engineering and business expertise
together to provide unconventional
solutions with companies like earth
spark and spark meter and we've done a
report for the UN foundation on best
practices for Rural Electric micro grids
all those solutions recognize that
people and technology are equally
important Anita what about the role of
diversity and getting better outcomes
well many of the problems that we have
been describing really rely on groups to
collaborate and so it's written some of
the problems persist because groups fail
to collaborate to come up with good
policy solutions to implement so we've
been looking at this problem of
collaboration in the framework of
collective intelligence historically
when we've thought about collective
intelligence it's been as a function of
the the skills of individual people we
think if we educate students well they
should go off and make smart teams well
in our research we haven't found that to
be the case that there really is a
quality that enables groups to
collaborate more effectively than others
that has thing has to do with other
aspects of the group
and so we've been doing a variety of
research studies over the last couple of
years both to measure collective
intelligence as well as to look at what
really leads to higher collective
intelligence and groups and so while we
have found that it's it's not about
individual IQ necessarily we have found
some other elements so one thing that we
have found and I think that's the yes
okay
one thing that we found initially we
found a correlation with the proportion
of women in the group and collective
intelligence and we thought it initially
it was a linear correlation now that
we've collected
data on several hundred groups we find
that actually it's it's a curvilinear
correlation so in this graph what you
see is that groups off will oscillate
around average collective intelligence
until they have majority women and
that's when they're reliably above
average collective intelligence and then
thank you and then but when it's all
women it goes back to being average so
there is a there is a benefit to having
gender diversity but with a tilt toward
having more women and one of the things
that we find when groups have more women
is that the quality of communication
tends to be higher there tends to be a
higher level of communication and more
equality in contribution to
communication and so that's one of the
reasons why we see this effect but said
another way as men become more skilled
in some of these collaboration abilities
then we should see maybe the effect of
simple gender composition decrease so
another thing that we find that enhances
collective intelligence is cognitive
diversity so we've measured a variety of
cognitive styles that actually
differentiate people who work in
different academic fields like we see at
CMU some of these cognitive styles are
predominant in engineering and
mathematics others and the arts and
still others in the humanities and so we
find in when we don't intervene that
groups that have at least a moderate
level of diversity tend to reach the
highest levels of collective
intelligence when we actually in some
studies intervene to help the diverse
groups collaborate more effectively we
see more of a linear effect where our
diversity continues to have greater
advantages but one thing we know from
trends you know across the world is that
if left to their own devices groups tend
not to be diverse we like to hang out
with people who are like us and so
groups won't achieve the highest levels
of collective intelligence unless they
make an active effort to increase their
diversity and so and that's true here at
CMU and in every organization across the
globe you've just given great empirical
cases for why the STG
is under goal five reducing inequality
increasing diversity makes sense
Marshall what about in your world
interconnectedness in robotics human
human aspects of yes much of the work in
robotics does not have to do with robots
it has to do with people understanding
people understanding their behavior
understanding their motion next one
please thank you
this is an example here from our
computer vision group of analysis of
people again understanding their action
understanding their behavior
understanding their their internal
states etc once we have those
capabilities we can we can develop new
applications this is an example here
next one please this is an example here
of an interaction between a protection
on your child in an autism study we can
now automatically analyze those
interactions and extract information we
can also analyze people in a deeper way
by recognizing their intent for example
if I move in this direction you can
guess that I'm trying to grasp this this
glass we can use this capability to now
have tied to interaction between systems
and people this is an example here from
experiment from Professor Han he had
money studying the effect of combining
the intent prediction from the system
with the actual person interaction with
the with the robot we can go much
further than that if we extend our reach
the next slide please this is an example
here of a collaboration between the
robotics team here at CMU the
engineering team at CMU and the
neurobiology department at the
University of Pittsburgh this is an
example here where a tetraplegic patient
a paralyzed patient is connected to a
robot arm using a brain computer
interface BCI
interface through this interface is able
to control the manipulator using a brain
signal basically using thoughts the
problem of course with this kind of
system is that they are limited in what
the
execute now if we can use what I just
said about recognizing intent the system
now can guess and understand what the
person is trying to do and now intervene
to actually help the system carry out
the task that she really wants to do the
night result next next one please and
you can play the movie is that now she's
able to carry out a task that was
absolutely impossible before for example
desta's which requires a rotational
motion which is impossible to brain the
right brain control it is now possible
because the system is able to recognize
her intent so this is an example where
we're giving a completely new capability
that was impossible before thanks to
this deeper understanding of people and
their interaction so Jake talk to us
about the combination of social economic
and cultural issues and how their inner
woven in technology so I think I I'm
gonna make a statement that is
potentially controversial at Carnegie
Mellon Farnum said it was okay if we
were troublemakers so so I feel like I
feel like I'm on the panel that's yeah
that's that's my job and what what I
think I really want to say is that
technology itself does not make the
world a better place it doesn't solve
social and political problems on its own
but it can play a very important role
and that's because technological systems
are incredibly complex mixtures of
networks people ideas social entities
practices behavior and things that we
don't even know about so if you want
technology to make a difference
you really have to design and engineer
these networks to do what you want them
to do because if you just put technology
out into the world it only replicates
the situation that it enters into it
might disrupt it and change things but
at the end of the day if you want
technology to make the world a better
place you have to develop an engineer
that technology to do so fortunately for
me and I think
one of the main reasons why I'm doing
what I'm doing today and not something
else is that Carnegie Mellon is actually
one of the few places in the world where
the kinds of interdisciplinary teams
necessary to do that are possible to put
together so I just wanted to tell a
little story
so back in 2010-2011 I was doing work on
civilian casualty recording and
estimation in times of conflict how many
people are dying in a conflict it turns
out that that's an incredibly difficult
task to carry out and so we were working
with statisticians we were working with
people in the field we were working with
demographers survey designers people at
human rights groups just trying to
figure out what's the best way of doing
this and you know I would go out and
talk to them and and and interview them
and at the end of the interviews they
would invariably say hey you're from
Carnegie Mellon I have this problem and
I don't really know how to solve it and
I need some help can you help me and in
some cases I said no we just don't have
that but in many of the cases actually
there was expertise here at Carnegie
Mellon that could have a direct impact
on data challenges that human rights
groups who are having and one of the big
ones was at this time the Syria conflict
was was just beginning and there was a
lot of video coming out there were you
know hundreds or thousands of videos
being posted to social media from Syria
any given day when I when I really
started a particular partnership that
I'll tell you about in a second when I
when we started that there were about
600,000 videos that was 2013 today I
don't even know nobody really knows how
many million and a half arm or not all
of them are relevant but a lot of them
give you information about human rights
violations and the the people who I was
trying to talk to about statistics and
survey design and demography and this
and that any other had videos that could
give them information about the problems
that we were all trying to address but
they didn't know how to to deal with
this massive volume and they said listen
it would really it would be really cool
if there was some system that could just
help us find things like tanks or
explosions or particular words
or even particular scenes or places is
there anyone at Carnegie Mellon who can
help help with this and I was like I
don't know I have no idea and one day I
was dropping my kids off or picking them
up actually from from daycare and
someone said well you should go talk to
yasser sheikh he's a he's a computer
vision person and I was like okay I'll
go talk to you sir so I went to talk to
you sir and he said listen this isn't
really what I work on but why don't you
come give a talk at the computer vision
seminar that we have weekly and he gave
me a slot and he said you know it's
actually the largest collection of
computer vision specialists in the world
and I was I mean I had no idea of my
background is in genetics and history
and science policy and you know pretty
diverse but nothing having to do with
how do you analyze video so I came and I
brought slides and I showed you know I
showed some some videos from Syria and I
said it would be really cool if we could
just have some system that tells us
about tanks you know when there are
explosions gunshots those kinds of
things when people say Allah Akbar or
something like that I know it's gonna
take millions of dollars and you know
five or six years but if anyone has any
ideas let me know so people raise their
hands and gave me some interesting
advice and at the end Alex Hoffman and I
apologize there are actually some people
from the an event I did in Philadelphia
in the audience and I told the story
then but I'm telling it again I told it
with Alex the last time but Alex comes
up to me after and he says hey I'm Alex
I just wanted to let you know that the
US government has given me ten million
dollars to solve this problem and it's
basically solved and because it's basic
science you're welcome to share it and
so with that I started sharing this
technology with the human rights
community and it's now I can't really
say who's using it but a lot of big
organizations and smaller organizations
are using it there was I think my time
is up but there was a video we've been
involved in some work in sin in Ukraine
and we've brought together collections
of people experts in architecture people
who do computer vision machine learning
someone like me who does who does
history and political work lawyers we've
brought people who are experts in
bringing evidence and visualizing data
and and it's only through these
intentional groups where you have a goal
and our goal is to make the world a
slightly better place by bringing human
rights violations to light that you can
actually create technologies that the
human rights community can use because
when this stuff is just sitting in
someone's lab or being used by the
intelligence community in the United
States or the military or big companies
the human rights community doesn't know
it exists and so we there has to be some
kind of interface and Carnegie Mellon
has become one of those interfaces and
it's really because I can go talk to
people in computer science and they're
happy to talk to me and we can work
together that we can do this we're gonna
stay on the theme of just
interdisciplinary in a second I just
wanted to add two points one is the
number that 200,000 people were killed
in Bosnia in the war in Bosnia was a
number that came out very early in the
war there was no actual empirical
evidence but it drove policy
conversations over and over and over
again when you think about the war in
Syria this is the most photographed war
ever it's great that ten million dollars
went into this but ultimately we haven't
solved the problem obviously and this
war continues the thing that that
evidence will be helpful for is the
eventual war crimes trials so let's talk
about the most interdisciplinary
collection working on energy
apparently anywhere in the world Jay
very challenge yeah microphone please
microphone is is climate change and you
know we've been successful in this
country in putting a fence around
conventional pollution when I started
studying this 15 years ago we were
killing 40,000 people a year prematurely
by pollution from electric power plants
in the u.s. now it's down to a little
bit below 10,000 that's a big success
but I am sorry to have to tell you that
we are solidly on track for putting four
times the amount of co2 in our
atmosphere then we had before the
Industrial Revolution four times
pre-industrial co2 is going to guarantee
us something like 11 degrees Fahrenheit
warmer planet then when my father
studied mechanical engineering right and
that is a different planet people here
have looked at what that does for
example to the output of power plants
but CMU is going to have to lead the way
in figuring out how to put teams
together of engineers scientists
economists and people who understand
behavior to figure out what that hotter
world is going to look like from an
engineering standpoint our students are
going to have to operate in that hot
planet 11 degrees Fahrenheit hotter than
we have and that is a tremendous
opportunity for a breathtaking change in
our curriculum and it's an
interdisciplinary one Nina can you talk
to us about collaboration in physical
space absolutely you know all of the
work that we're doing on collective
intelligence is inherently
interdisciplinary we can't connect
problem solvers across the globe
without heavy involvement from folks in
computer science as well as people who
understand behavior you know both
cognitive psychology social psychology
people who study culture and so here
it's been very easy to accomplish this
both in terms of you know physical
layout especially now that we've
relocated here it's easy to entice my
computer science colleagues to come
across the street and see the new
building and get some good coffee so you
know stuff like that matters but also
you know just in terms of the the
culture of the school you know there are
places where you know certain kinds of
publications wouldn't count you know
before you have tenure in here that that
kind of thing has never been an issue or
who you get grants with and and that
sort of thing and so you know that's
been a critical part of fostering the
kinds of things that we've been able to
do the platform's that we've created for
collecting data and for fostering
collaboration across the universities
who are involved in the projects it's so
clear that if you're gonna solve these
complex problems you have to have people
hope that have different skills the rest
of our conversation is going to riff
back and forth between both the positive
and the negative aspects of Technology
we're gonna turn to Marshall now to show
us for lack of a better word some very
cool applications of Technology and how
they intersect with with humans thank
you yes let me show you a couple of
example of evolving technology from the
initial stage to applications that
matter to people let me start with the
first example here this is an example
from the our bio robotics lab this is a
collection of robots that was developed
over the years for a number of
applications from manufacturing
inspection evolving to search-and-rescue
et cetera next one please if you make
this this robot small enough you can
actually get inside the body this is an
example here with the thing beating on
you on your right is their heart and the
robot
quarreling on the surface of the heart
this robot is now certified for surgery
in fact a surgical team at the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
next door uses it for major surgery such
as throat cancer removal and surgery
like this this leads to the vision of
surgery without incision which basically
is a saving life-saving type of type of
surgery so this is an example here where
the initial research limited to robotics
leads to an application that is
literally life life-saving let me show
you another another example this example
comes from our applied machine learning
group from Professor Archer Dubrowski
that lab worked for many years on
basically data analytics machine
learning technology for variety of
applications predictive maintenance etc
then this lab linked up with a student
actually a student from the Hine school
Emily Kennedy who was interested in
policy and a societal issue and there
again the connection of the technology
with the human application area led to
the realization that this technology
could be used very effectively for
combating human trafficking this led to
an extensive research program this led
to accompany this led to a suite of
software that is now used by hundreds of
law enforcement organization throughout
the country and has led to arrests of
traffickers and most importantly
liberation of victims including children
so those are examples were the initial
technology development through the
connectedness with other other part of
the universities other part of the
ecosystem leads to new applications that
are in this case literally life saving
your life transforming so Marshall
didn't know it but he's out there
advancing five point two eight point
seven and sixteen point two which are
all commitments that we globally have
made to end human trafficking so thank
you for your work
Anita talk to us about the way in which
you know a lot of times we're worried
about
technology replacing people certainly
the work of the black Center is going to
be looking a lot at the future of work
and workers yeah absolutely and actually
some of our work with collective
intelligence is now being folded in with
what the block Center is doing in a
variety of different organizations but
as as I described when I was talking
about what contributes to collective
intelligence you know what we see is
essentially collective intelligence is
built upon both the quality of some
qualities or skills of the people in the
in the collective as well as the quality
of their connections and so a lot of
times when we think about technology
especially in AI and when you read about
the fear that's out there in
organizations and in the general public
it's it's really fear about you know the
robots coming and taking over jobs and
you know making certain skills obsolete
and that falls into the category of what
we call production technologies the
computer is taking in the place of
humans or at least making them more
efficient such that fewer humans are
needed to do the work and that's that's
an issue societally that we need to
really deal with there's another class
of technology however and it's the one
that we focus on more in the work and
collective intelligence which we call
coordination technology and this is the
technology used to connect the humans to
enhance the collaboration that's
possible the nature of the communication
the amount and the quality of
communication and so that's what we are
really focusing on in our work on
collective intelligence how can we make
you know all collectives operate at the
highest level possible even if they
don't have the people with the social
skills for example can we men the nature
of the the communication processes so
that they're more effective can we you
know prime people so that they'll maybe
pay attention to the fact that they're
dominating the conversation and they
should let some other people in and so
we some work with Laura - over in HCI I
we look at synchrony and various
physiological cues and when people pick
up on the fact that others have negative
facial expressions and synchronize with
those we see that the group has
higher collective intelligence well is
there a way to actually you know prime
people to pay attention to these things
if they're not necessarily doing so on
their own so those are the kinds of
interventions that we're looking at in
using technology to foster better
communication across humans so we're
gonna dig deep now into this positive
and negative aspects
I'm gonna be teaching a course starting
in January that looks at advancing
democracy and human rights in the 21st
century which is code for how has
technology and innovation both helped
and hurt so on the positive side
you know the Twitter revolution the Arab
Awakening was really very much driven by
social media but then we have to deal
with the backlash and also the fact that
people didn't necessarily know how to
organize we have an ongoing mass
atrocity in rahega
with the wrecking go but we have drones
that are actually able to capture film
and that will be used both in the UN but
in in international courts I know Jay
that you have lots to say about this
certainly is a Russia specialist I've
been very focused on the impact of the
Russians not spending very much money
frankly I mean the the hacking the troll
farms you know a million here million
there all things said not a lot of money
given the amount of chaos and
uncertainty that they've they've
engendered so I just um if I may just
make a couple of quick points um one is
that I think my proudest achievement
here at Carnegie Mellon was actually
sending Emily over to talk to Artur I
don't know if you know this but Emily
was actually my student and she was
doing you know what I thought was
interesting research on how the Internet
is changing human trafficking and I was
like honestly Emily like we know that I
think what would be really interesting
if you actually tried to do something
about it why don't you go talk to the
people here at Carnegie Mellon who are
engaged in network analysis and see see
if there's anything to be done I had no
idea I mean I love I love Emily I I had
so much faith in her I had no idea what
she was going to do and I just it was
it's an amazing story like if if I never
do anything again I'll feel like I'll
have accomplished something by just
sending her
retired tourists it was cool to see that
so the second thing is the the
interactions that Marshall is showing
where that child the in the autism study
we're actually being done in a room in
the basement of Wien is in the basement
of lean and what's that room called so
so it's called the panopticon
essentially which is the picture that I
don't know if you'll is here but it's
it's really interesting that these
technologies have multiple valances and
many uses I'm teaching a course on
surveillance now and I actually start
with that image so it's very interesting
that the panopticon that's you know
watching us and and we're Marcia was
talking about a pen optic classroom
there's a lot of good that can come out
of that but there's also a lot of bad
that can come out of that like if the
university starts evaluating our
behavior in the classroom based on
cameras that they put how does that
change the relationship between the
student and the teacher so these are
these are things that we have to think
very carefully about one of the in in as
far as anita was talking one of the
things that I sort of enter into
conversations with human rights
colleagues is that AI and machine
learning cannot and will not and will
never replace human judgment and human
knowledge what they can do is like any
other power tool whether it's a saw or a
you know a screwdriver or something like
that no matter what it is they can make
the human more effective and more
efficient but I really don't think they
can replace the human you know maybe in
surgery we can argue that in some cases
they can but certainly when it comes to
human judgment we're never going to
replace human judgment so I always ask
human rights colleagues what is your
goal what's your intention and sometimes
technology can help get you there like
if you want to show that some particular
behavior is systemic and you have a
million and a half videos you're never
going to be able to get through them and
find all of the instances but machine
learning and computer vision can help
you in that case bringing it before a
judge and convincing a judge that this
is a pattern that actually matters and
that requires some form of justice and
accountability isn't something
that machine learning and computer
vision and AI can do so we need to we
need I think we need to learn when these
tools can help us and when we should
just put them down and go sit in a room
without cameras without technology
without our cell phones and actually
talk and try and figure out what matters
to us and so I think that Carnegie
Mellon is actually a place where you can
do that so I think I'll stop there and
let others this morning when I woke up
on MSNBC the editor of Wired was on and
there's gonna be a new issue called AI
and the cold war or the coming cold war
and it's looking at the role that AI is
how it's being used by various
governments that are trying to crack
down on their their population so it's
absolutely something that colleagues at
CMU would be in a great position to help
address it's it's critical for the kind
of future we want to see when we were
here yesterday talking among ourselves
and we were going down a sort of dark
hole and sort of saying things have
gotten worse
J was very smart to argue actually
things are better than they've been can
I ask you to talk a little bit about
that sure you can ask yourself are you
better off than your parents and if
you're in almost any country in the
world
the answer is dramatically better people
live longer they are wealthier and they
are much much healthier get on the
internet and look at the heat late
Hans roebling's videos where he has this
animated graph where he has wealth on a
logarithmic axis on the horizontal axis
and long life on the other axis in all
the countries in the MU in the world are
moving from the lower left to the upper
right rapidly and a lot of that is due
to technology including electricity the
Green Revolution vaccines and so we have
lots to be thankful for but human nature
doesn't change
and all of these technologies are used
for good and ill but the fact is that
the base rates of death early death the
base rates of disease and of poverty are
all getting much much better and you had
some statistics specific ones so there
was a predecessor to the sustainable
development goals called the Millennium
Development Goals which ran from 2000 to
2015 this was a set of goals that were
really put together by a handful of men
it was mostly men in a closed room but
they were they were aspirational and
they were about reducing poverty and
reducing maternal death and they had an
impact by 2015 the number of people
living in extreme poverty on the planet
had reduced from 26% in 2002 or 1990 to
10% in 2015
right so 26% to 10%
this is according to the World Bank that
is the power of collective action that
is what the MDGs delivered imagine what
it's like when that energy involves us
also working on us that it's the
sustainable development goals it's not
just about the global North talking
about the so-called global South that's
why I think there's an enormous power
and potential possibly but I welcome a
frank conversation about the pros and
cons the difficulties there's certain
aspects of the sustainable development
goals clearly that CMU is already
working on and their parts that they're
not gonna be able to work on but even to
be a first mover and champion other
universities I think it's it's an
extremely important time and it's an
extremely important role so I'm with
that I want to I want to thank our
colleagues if you have any parting shots
that you want to make this would be the
time
no I'm then I want to thank you very
much for your attention and I want to
invite president
which would you prefer president doctor
that's what I told her president dr.
Farnum dhania please come to the stage
[Applause]
well thank you Sarah for leading that
discussion and and many thanks to all of
our panelists this afternoon for
demonstrating how CMU's researchers are
enriching and impacting lives here in
our region as well as around the world
please join me once again
thank you CY my job is so easy I have to
represent this this is so remarkable so
amazing as we heard today the underlying
culture cultural social and economic
factors behind some of the society's
most complex challenges require
collaboration across many disciplines
here at CMU this collaboration is woven
into the fabric of our culture and our
human centered approach gives us a
unique advantage in understanding
behavior data and impact I hope all of
you enjoyed today's symposium as much as
I did I am so honored and humbled by
your presence at today's conversations
and at all the inauguration festivities
today each and every member of our
community has a role to play in writing
the next exciting chapter of Carnegie
Mellon University I think we all can
agree that our future is an inspiring
one this weekend's festivities actually
are not over it's Homecoming weekend for
us
so I hope that you will join me and our
colleagues for our homecoming
festivities tomorrow they start at 7:00
a.m. I'll be up and running and the game
against Geneva starts at 1:00 p.m.
p.m. I hope to see you all there and
thank you again for joining us enjoy
yours
[Applause]
you